music's biggest night is back and in the
entertainment capital of the world
because the grammys are live from las
vegas on april 3rd that's right we spoke
to host trevor noah once again this time
about the lineup
the grammys will be in las vegas for the
first time and after a year with no
audience the show is expecting a lot of
energy this year comedian trevor noah is
hosting for the second time and plans to
marry last year's dynamic with this
year's show trying time for everybody in
the world so i i hope that that element
carries forward whilst also multiplying
it by the joy of all the people who are
in the room so that's what that's what
this year's grammy is going to feel like
it's going to be
as intimate as last year's but then with
a certain air of relaxation that that we
didn't get the luxury of having last
time around this year the grammys are
live from the mgm brand with
performances from bts olivia rodrigo and
little nos x noah says he doesn't know
whose performance he wants to see most
you know this there's moments like that
that you don't expect you you don't know
who's going to bring something out you
don't know who's going to do something
different you don't know who's going to
roll out a giant bed and twerk on it
well this year there are a few new
categories and more nominees in the big
four we're talking about best new album
best new song best new record and best
new artist regardless of what type of
artist you are
there is a certain recognition
that you get from your industry and your
peers
that has almost as much weight as the
love and adoration of your fans does
[Music]
and you're gonna have some special
coverage for us that evening that's
right everyone's so excited just to be
there and just basically just be here in
las vegas